los arrecifes de coral son parte de los
más espectaculares ecosistemas del
planeta estos son algunos de los grandes
interrogantes que enfrentan hoy los
biólogos de conservación marina pero
cómo podemos proteger los arrecifes y
los animales y plantas que dependen de
ellos y cómo podemos asegurarnos de que
nuestras áreas protegidas no sean
perjudiciales para las personas que
utilizan los arrecifes para sobrevivir
tomemos a fiji como ejemplo
fiyi se compone de una serie de islas en
el océano pacifico sur
los científicos sugirieron que en lugar
de un gran parque que provee muchísima
cobertura para un sistema de recife
mientras deja al resto desprotegido una
mejor manera es crear un sistema de
áreas protegidas anidadas juntas como
perlas en un collar la única manera de
que esta red de reservas funcione es
conectando cada parque con los otros
parques hay dos principales beneficios
de esto primero que todo protección si
algo malo ocurre en un parque digamos un
derrame de petróleo o decoloración de
los corales entonces puesto
que el parque parte de un sistema puede
ser resembrado de los parques que se
libraron del evento el segundo beneficio
es la representación mediante la
conservación de muchas áreas diferentes
los científicos se aseguran que muchos
hábitats diferentes están protegidos de
esta forma se pueden asegurar de que
todos los diferentes hábitats marinos
dempsey y tales como arrecifes de coral
manglares y hierbas marinas estén todos
representados de esta manera no
colocamos indebidamente a ningún pueblo
en particular o grupo de personas bajo
la carga económica de tener sus barcos
de pesca fuera de los límites y tener
entonces los científicos deben
asegurarse de que aquellos parques más
pequeños estén conectados porque si no
lo están probablemente no serán auto
sustentables pero como lo hacemos al
observar cuán estrechamente relacionados
están los peces recíprocamente en cada
una de estas reservas en fiji los
científicos pueden comprender
precisamente cuánta migración procederá
entre las reservas dentro del sistema
ahora si observamos detalladamente
bastantes especies podemos distinguir si
el collar está funcionando o no lo que
los científicos han descubierto hasta
ahora es que en general existe una buena
suma de conectividad entre los parques
al interior de fiyi pero esto no es
precisamente una gran libre competencia
más bien se cree que algunas especies
recién nacidas en el extremo occidente
tienen dificultades para llegar a las
islas en el extremo oriente para ayudar
a lidiar con esto los biólogos de
conservación sugieren que existan
suficientes parques tanto en el oriente
como en occidente para mantener
saludables a las poblaciones y de esta
manera podemos mantener el bello collar
que es nuestro arrecife de coral intacto